je suis enquêtrice au bureau du
procureur quand on ment quand on fait du
mal aux gens on nous sanctionne vous
avez déjà poursuivi une boîte aussi
énorme que perdu Pharma
le comportement humain a deux
composantes que l'on peut considérer
comme essentiel le fuir la douleur à
tout prix et aller vers le plaisir
douleur plaisir douleur plaisir mais si
on se positionne juste à cet endroit
pile entre la douleur et le plaisir
l'argent ne sera plus jamais un problème
la douleur n'est plus quelque chose que
l'on doit tolérer nous avons une réponse
à la douleur comment un médicament
prescrit de manière légale pouvait-il
tuer autant de monde donnez-moi les mots
que vous associez à l'oxycodone l'oxygo
les oxydavres je vous demande pardon ne
mettez pas ça dans vos notes nous
faisons l'objet d'investigation
vous pouvez me dire tout ce que vous
savez sur l'oxyde Quentin vous aimez les
films d'horreur
vous tous vous devrez faire autre chose
convaincre les médecins de prendre la
douleur au sérieux l'OxyContin une fois
qu'on l'a commencé il faut le garder
plus vous le prescrirez et plus vous
offrez les patients c'est désormais la
marque de pioïde numéro 1 dans tout le
pays
cette drogue s'infiltre dans les
moindres recoins de notre communauté
vous êtes la plus jolie minette vendeuse
d'OxyContin qu'on ait vu dans mon
cabinet
[Musique]
si le traitement marche à l'évidence ça
marche on peut augmenter le dosage je
vais vous passer à 40 ml c'est pas
seulement des individus ça détruit les
familles
les amis vous n'êtes qu'une diseuse avec
une queue de cheval vous avez acheté
votre voiture grâce à la mort d'une
fille de 16 ans
pareil que n'importe quel dealer de
crack aux États-Unis à part qu'elle on
les récompense
il y a que cette info
ils savent qu'ils tuent des gens par
milliers
chars
mais félicitations pour l'argent gagné
monsieur
merci
si vous ne vous coupez pas je vais vous
renverser avec ma voiture et
écrabouillez votre de crâne
[Musique]
et vous me filerez de l'OxyContin pour
que j'ai moins mal
[Musique]